we're ready for the second part of the
evening for the second talk we have
cabin kavanah comes from Columbia
welcome and it's going to tell us about
AI and auscultation
please welcome Teddy thank you so much
can you hear me can you hear me okay
perfect
good evening everybody today I'm going
to talk about AI and ask rotation I'm
going to show my participation using
Python in a very promising idea of
innovation in the medical industry we
have been working from Colombia oh wait
okay I'm going to start my presentation
by introducing myself after I'm going to
talk a little bit about some background
information I'm going to talk about the
problem I'm going to talk about
auscultation and the status cope what
that is
and also we cannot talk about these two
things without introducing the heart
sound and how does it look like I'm
going to talk also about words
initiatives what researches and in
different places around the world have
been working in the same in this thing's
topic and oh and after I will talk a
little bit about my project the
development of algorithms in to analyze
hearts on signals and at the end I will
talk a little bit about some summary
well it's no work alright this is me
I'm Kevin as I say from Cali Colombia
please do not talk about and think about
colleague or tell or any of those stuff
narcos and necklace Cali is a really
nice city in Colombia located on the
southwest of the country and I know all
of you or many of you have watched the
work up and it's very easy now to remind
us by the Columbia football team we
almost won almost I am a biomedical
graduate student from Universidad marks
ENT nice Green University in Cali and a
biomedical engineer it's simply a person
who learned from medicine and
engineering to try to apply solutions to
solve medical issues or health problems
right so after I finished my
undergraduate studies I decided to join
or which I can join a good group of
people and start developing real case
solutions in medical problems so I make
a proposal to dr. randall's Bumble and I
started working as a volunteer research
assistant in the cardiovascular medicine
and specialities of high complexity
research group in funda Jian clinic a
Shia it's one of the best hospitals in
cardiovascular diseases in Columbia and
it's directed by dr. Jorge Ramos
actually his middle Colombian and Middle
English this guy this Raynaud's have
developed one of the first pacemakers in
1958 this was very inspirational with
for me and he since dance he has been a
pioneer in things make pacemaker face
maker technology there I have been
working with recording hearts on signals
from healthy patients mostly in order to
analyze how or which patterns we can
extract from healthy patients with
healthy heart sounds and see how we can
create a signature of the heart sound in
this type of patients and that's mostly
what I have been working over there so
what's the problem behind this research
or why is this important you will see
cardiovascular disease it's why this
research is very important according to
the World Health Organization
cardiovascular disease is the leading
global cost of death in Colombia for
example a cardiovascular disease caused
the 29 percent of all deaths in the
whole country in the UK 26 percent of
all deaths corresponds to cardiovascular
disease actually the difference now
really big between the two countries
80% of all cardiovascular
are caused by heart attacks and stroke
and the most important thing is it's
been projected by 2030 to cause more
than 22 millions of deaths every year so
this is alarming isn't it hmm now one of
the first steps doctors uses to analyze
the cardiovascular system is the
occupation of the patient right if you
any of you have been in medical
[Music]
consultation the doctor normally takes
his stethoscope and analyze the sounds
or the heart or the lungs which are the
sounds inside your body so let's talk a
little bit about what's auscultation and
and what's the aesthetic scope so as I
say auscultation is the action of
listening to the sounds inside the human
body
this could be the heart sound the lung
sounds the abdomen for instance
auscultation it's being reported a long
time ago the 5th century BC by
Hippocrates he used to he was a doctor
he used to use his ear to listen to the
sounds inside the human body but
nowadays auscultation is being performed
by an stethoscope however the
stethoscope has not always been as
nowadays and I'm going to show that this
is the first invention of the status
coke invented by doctor
Rene Laennec in 1819 it was made by wood
it was monaural which means the doctors
were able to analyze the heart stone
with one ear or the other years later
dr. Church chemin invented the first
binaural a stethoscope patients doctors
were able to analyze the heart sound and
to listen to the heart stone with both
ears almost a century later
Western Electric developed the first
electronic stethoscope now doctors were
able to listen to the heart stone and
control the volume and even apply analog
filters in order to listen to the hearts
ins more clearly in different bands
nobody's doctors use the classic leadmon
status Coke in Baden invented by dr.
Littman in 1961 and the status quo
itself keeps changing there has been
more technology being applied in the
stethoscope and now we can find in the
market in hardware speaking a
stethoscope with the capacity of sending
and sending the heart sound signal to a
computer to be able to analyze the heart
sound and even send the hearts on signal
to another colleague in a different
country so this is very interesting
inventions are not made just by a single
person inventions are contributions for
people in different part of the world so
it's important to see what world's
initiatives have been doing
one important thing is to realize that
people who are not able to have access
to hard sounds they are not able to find
public databases in order to start
developing algorithms to classify or
process the Heartstone signal one of the
of those public databases are really
likely is provided by fishermen they
also provide different type of
physiological signals including heart
sound signals they have more than 4,000
recorded heart sounds from healthy and
unhealthy patients and this is a very
important contribution to people who is
trying to work with heart sound
recognition there are also more
databases as well but the one I really
like is fishing net this is very
important I think very important
achievement resources in different
countries actually he's in Texas and
well Denmark the they have been working
and investigating using digital
stethoscope analyzing the heart sound in
healthy patients and also analyzing the
signature of the hearts of in patients
with coronary artery disease which is
another type of cardiovascular disease
and they have found differences induced
by this tent placement sometimes where
patients have coronary artery disease
they need to they require a stent
placement and they have found
differences induces by this little
device in the heart song and I think
this is a really really important
achievement and when talking about this
kind of technology because if we are
able to analyze or identify differences
may buy this device is in the heart zone
it could be a really nice approach if we
keep doing research and with this
signals so that's a important approach
also is very curious how algorithms have
been applied in image recognition or
artificial vision are also being applied
in the hearts of signal basically
resources by transforming the signal
from amplitude and time domain to
frequency domain or Melk officiants are
able to apply vision recognition to
classify the heart zone signal as
pathological or known pathological and I
think that's also very interesting now
going to introduce what is a heart sound
before explaining this image in the
right side I will play a normal heart
zone a bit so if you
[Music]
[Music]
so there's a dundun dundun or doctors
called this laptop right this laptop we
call this laptop the two principal
components of the heart sound signal and
we call it s1 and s2 physicians in order
to make the diagnosis of a patient when
they are performing the auscultation
procedure they need to listen very
carefully to these two segments and
identify they they need to identify
abnormalities between s1 and s2 and also
abnormalities between s 2 and s 1 and
then this gives information to the
physician to in order to classify the
heart some so there's a very quick
explanation of it now well have been
working on using Python ok first then I
know this is now Matt de to London but
my the first the first tax I needed to
work on was to pass some algorithms from
MATLAB to Python and well it was very
easy it was not difficult there are lots
of tutorials out there people can use in
order to work with Python and start
programming with Python
so first challenge was to develop an
algorithm to perform the segmentation of
the heart sound as I say
[Music]
doctors needed needs to classify the
heart zone and separate s1 and from x2
with the same we perform we develop an
algorithm which works very well as you
can see in this graph in the third row
these are classifications or
identification sorry of each of the
segments that was the first task second
we have been working with signal
processing techniques in order to
develop digital filters in Python in
order to analyze the heart zone signals
in different bands low medium and high
frequency bands could be others I will
show I will play a little bit this son
so you can appreciate the differences so
this is a low a heart zone in low
frequencies normal rang and this is a
[Music]
medium frequencies now high frequencies
this is very important because we can
extract information within the signals
analyzing different bands and use this
information to fit machine learning
algorithms to classify the signal we
have been also using fast Fourier
transform to transform the signal from
time domain to a frequency domain and
analyze the frequency components in the
whole signals and each segments of the
signals we have also worked
the spectrogram in order to analyze the
variation in frequency and time and I
will show in the next life so this is a
known pathological heart song when
doctor use when the doctors are using
the stethoscope they are not able to
view anything in the signal just they
just use the capacity of listening to
classify the signal and to give their
diagnosis and it's very interesting how
we or how it's being introduced a
picture of the heart sound in order to
give more information to the physician
in order to better classify a heart son
this is how it sounds like
the image above is the spectrogram
frequency over time and the image below
is the funnel cardiogram amplitude
versus time and we can for example we
can see in the second graph how it's a
normal distribution and we can also see
like the s 1 and s 2 components normally
and also this components creates signal
in the frequency domain which goes from
low frequencies to high frequencies
constantly now let's analyze or let's
see how it looks
pathological Hertz on and let's listen
to pathological Horton well it's there
is anybody able to told me if he can
differentiate on normal from the normal
heart sound just with the sound is it
clear yeah okay well there are hearts on
which are not very clear to identify and
in this cases we're not able to use
images which gives a little bit of more
information in order to classify this
heart sense
so that's a really really nice approach
and all these animations are being made
also using Python
and well I I am NOT allowed to talk more
too much about this approaches since we
published but we have been also working
in biological inspire algorithms this
our net neural networks inspired by the
human brain and specifically in auditory
system were utilizing or using the some
of the structures in this part of the
brain to develop our algorithms or
neural algorithms and we have been able
to classify sorry to identify the
segments s1 and s2 automatically just
passing the whole signal through the
neurons and the neurons one of them are
able to fire when it's when we have
sorry when when they are when they
identify the one each of the segments s1
or s2 all right any of you have been
working with QT good well for those who
say who raise their hands
QT is a very nice platform to develop
not just graphical user interfaces but
also we to show their visualization
techniques it's a very nice platform and
it has a lot of libraries with Python in
order to either develop graphical user
interfaces from Python or directly from
QT we
have been working on how to show to the
physicians the information because this
it's it's also important not just to say
this is an unhealthy heart son or
healthy heart sound but also to show the
information so the physician it's the
one that takes the decision in in in in
today make the diagnosis of a patient
right so it's been very important for us
to develop a prototype of graphical user
interfaces to show the information to
the physician so to close I think
AI it's also moving to the occupation
specifically and this approaches are
being shown that it could help
physicians to better take their their
diagnosis using different techniques in
the hospital we have been working trying
to create a signature of a normal heart
zone in order to better classify their
hearts on signals in patients also it is
important and this is kind of a race
because there are many people around the
globe working in this same topic and the
computer interaction between the Machine
and the doctor it's a very important
challenge because doctors are very
skeptical about using this kind of
technology because
well this idea that the doctor that the
yeah the doctor is going to be replaced
by the machine but I think doctors
should use it should embrace artificial
intelligence in this kind of techniques
in order to better develop to you know
to drive hell how do you say that yeah
you know a doctor should use this kind
of technology to better develop their
procedures and it's they need to see
this as a tool and also an enemy okay
right so some of the things I can show
are here my github account this is a
library an open source library of
algorithms I develop this with my friend
Nikolas and and well this is free for
everybody interesting that's it
I think you're going
questions time for a couple of questions
hello Hey hello great job thanks very
much
really learned a lot about that I was
wondering you show this new status code
right that the electronic one where you
can send recordings of heartbeats around
do you know if there's an effort also to
kind of collect that data and kind of
move it to this physio net and kind of
improve the data set as is available or
is that not yet done like if it is say
well what I know it's the official net
they have different research group there
have been contributed with more hearts
on signal and not just hearts on signals
but electroencephalography or
electromyography signal different type
of physiological signals and this
research groups mostly located in the
u.s. feed fish unit and future net also
have different challenge challenges and
and they already have their partners
which provide these signals now well
this electronic stethoscope is it's been
released by liepman I don't know
anything about if lead man has a kind of
contract with them to try to provide
this signals this Lichtman stethoscope
is is being used by private doctors so I
don't know if if they are also able to
share the information from patients
that's a really specific thing
and more question yes I microphone
please
totally on the sit in front of us might
it's good to switch it down
I mean sorry I didn't kept have you
thought then it tries to pick up of any
abnormal abnormalities okay the first
question now I don't know any model
which replicates the heart zone but
that's very interesting so now I don't I
haven't heard about it
the second thing yeah there are
different devices actually Apple has in
some of their phones an app capable to
measure healthy parameters from their
users and I know that one of them is the
heart zone but I think this should be
more in hints of the physicians and not
the
the actual patients because well I
imagine if I able to have phoned can
tells me when my heart sound is good or
or not if we have if I have the power of
that technology well I will be running
all the days to the to the hospital and
tell the hey doctor look my my app is
telling me the my heart is it's not
working properly and well I think this
will be a little kind of crisis what I
think it's the the signals should be
sent to private doctors now I don't know
if any of you have heard about Babylon
so this company is working with doctors
online able to make diagnosis with the
patient's online and I think this
technologies should be articulated with
this kind of infrastructure instead of
just given the you know the the power of
analyze your body by itself I think
that's my opinion
so we should we should wrap it up we're
running out of time we'll be around for
the rest of the evening
you can continue the D conversational
cabin later let's thank having one more
time
[Applause]